a nomination for Best New Artist how
about that I know I can't believe it I'm
really excited yeah yeah no it's my
first time here at the at the Grammys
I'm in the carpet with my mom it's great
so you brought your mama is your date
tonight she's over there she is have
mama look how pretty she is she's super
cute okay so the story is you taught
yourself to sing from YouTube yeah yeah
I looked up on YouTube how to get
vibrato and then I started looking at
singing videos here she is mama
what's the if you could give me the
first lesson on how to sing vibrato what
would that be teach me okay so it's the
oscillation between two notes all right
that's what we brought over and it's
like oh
so what I would teach you okay there's
one method that worked for me you sit
down
and and you just you hold out one note
as long as you can
[Music]
and then when you start running out of
breath you bend over like this and then
it'll start it'll start to do the
oscillation
you're almost at it
it took me forever it took me like weeks
before I even felt a little bit of
oscillation but Evergreen has been such
a crazy
thing it really changed my life it's
beautiful yeah you released the debut
album last spring and it's just still
been on the charts oh thank you so much
yeah I know it's insane it's surreal to
have something that you know you're
proud of out into the world and you know
I got the chance to tour it and you know
everything that comes with it all the
all the benefits of that but yeah it's
been insane it's been a crazy ride Mama
you're the best date ever tonight how
proud are you of this oh my God I'm so
proud of that of my baby um I feel so
happy to be here thank you everybody to
make possible this moment she's ripping
out the big words tonight
who are you
who are you like that stage you gotta
see Bad Bunny
you gotta see Bad Bunny
[Music]